parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
iprema votre partenaire pour un
développement
[Musique]
durable bonjour bienvenue dans équilibre
le magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable au sommaire de ce
numéro pour lutter contre les mauvaises
herbes nous utilisons souvent du
dsherban des produits dangereux les
communes réduisent petit à petit leur
usage comme à Manille et amau où nous
sommes rendus une application de
covoiturage domicile travail lance un
défi à ses utilisateurs nous avons
rencontré son fondateur un coiffeur
versailla utilise depuis 17 ans des
produits exclusivement bio nous nous
sommes rendus dans son salon pour voir
comment il travaille ça y est les fêtes
sont terminées les décorations sont
enlevées mais souvent on ne sait pas
quoi faire de notre sapin plusieurs
communes ont décidé de les ramasser
c'est le cas de Voisins le bretonneux
qui les valorise pour ses espaces verts
un sujet de Catherine zulato et Elod
moine vos sapins de Noël s'offrent une
seconde vie ici à voisin le Bretonneux
pour la première année après les fêtes
se points de collecte ont été aménagés
dans la ville pour recevoir les
conifères c'est un moyen d'éviter que ça
traî n'importe où mais c'est surtout un
moyen de les valoriser et de les
recycler ensuite dans les différents
massifs de la ville au début on était
très modeste on tablait sur 150 à 200
sapins vu que c'était la première
opération et là nous en sommes à plus de
800 sapins donc on peut dire que c'est
un succès seul les sapins non floqués
pouvait être déposé car le flocquage ne
se recycle pas une fois collecté les
sapins sont ensuite tronçonnés et broyés
sur place l'utilisation de ces broyades
de conifè va nous permettre d'épendre ce
broyage sur les massifs et ainsi
d'éviter la la pousse des mauvaises
herbes et puis de Ben de tenir un peu au
chaud aussi les les massifs et ça va
finir aussi par faire un amandement si
vous voulez naturel sur les massifs le
produit des sapins de Noël est ainsi
répandu sur les massifs notamment de
bruyère la ville réfléchit également à
revaloriser d'autres déchets vers issus
des 4500 foyers vcinois une démarche qui
s'inscrit plus largement dans une
obligation européenne pour les communes
d'accéder au zéro phyo c'est-à-dire à
l'arrêt de l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires pesticides et autres
herbicides c'est prévu pour
2020 le zer phyo vous l'avez entendu les
communes doivent le respecter d'ici 2020
mais certaines d'entre elles sont déjà
bien engagé c'est le cas de manilamo le
16 décembre dernier elle a reçu le
diplôme du trefle phitoc cité 2014 un
reportage avec Elo di moine et William
l ce sont ces petits brin d'herme qui
posent soucis inoffensif mais parfois
disgracieux pour les faire disparaître
les communes utilisaient ce qu'on
appelle les produits
phytosanitaires aujourd'hui quand on
traite un espace vert en produit
chimiques si on en traitait encore il
faut fermer suivant les produits entre
24 et 48 he ça montre bien
que ces produits ne sont pas neutres
depuis 2009 la commune de manie a réduit
de 80 % sa consommation plusieurs sites
ont été des lieux témoins car assemblant
des difficultés
les sites pilotes on avait une rue on
avait une école on avait le centre de
loisirs on avait le cimetière ça nous a
permis dès 2009 de d'imaginer les
techniques de
substitution on est avec des essais he
plus ou moins réussi d'ailleurs sur les
techniques de de
substitution le paillage ça ça marche
très très bien sur l'ensemble de nos
espaces de no le but pour la commune
atteindre le Z phyo les agents
techniques utilisent de nouvelles
méthodes ou plutôt d'anciennes
aujourd'hui on utilise quasiment plus
rien à part quelques produits comme des
antilimas mais le reste tout est fait à
la main par les soit par nos agents soit
en partenariat avec des
associations locales prochaine étape
l'information auprès du citoyen car si
les routes et les chaussées sont à la
charge de la mairie les trottoirs
doivent être entretenus par nous les
habitants mais si les mauvaises herbes
poussent quand on est à la campagne
c'est peut-être aussi un peu
normal on connaît le covoiturage pour
faire de long trajet mais depuis
quelques mois une application propose de
trouver des covoitureurs pour faire des
déplacements domicile travail l'équipe
créatrice lance même un concours avec
William elle et Louise bois nous sommes
allés à leur rencontre lors de la
présentation de ce concours dans un
grand groupe à Guill encours
nous sommes avec Julien honard le
fondateur de l'application bonjour
Julien bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez tout d'abord me parler de cette
application alors WAZ up c'est une
application de covoiturage spécialisée
sur les trajets domicile travail en fait
c'est un covoiturage très différent du
covoiturage qu'on connaît plus qu le
covoiturage longue distance là en fait
il s'agit vraiment de covoiturer tous
les jours pour aller au travail et du
coup on a développé une solution
spécifique pour répondre à un maximum de
des contraintes que peuvent avoir les
salariés sur ces trajet là mais pourquoi
vous êtes concentré sur domicile travail
finalement vous sentiez qu'il y avait un
besoin parce qu'on voit toujours les
gens seuls dans leur voiture ouais tout
à fait je crois que c'est euh euh plus
de 80 % des personnes qui sont seules
dans leur voiture le matin pour aller au
travail euh et en plus aujourd'hui on
travaille avec des entreprises qui sont
pas forcément très bien desservies par
les transports en commun euh donc ont
besoin de nouvelles solutions de
mobilité pour leurs salariés euh et le
covoiturage s'il fonctionne avec un vrai
réseau euh de transport alternatif euh
permet de répondre à à ces besoins des
salariés actuellement combien de
personnes utilisent déjà votre
application sur cqutin en fait on a créé
un réseau de covoiturage où 8 personnes
sur 10 trouvent au moins un covoitureur
et 60 % en trouvent plus de qu alors
pourquoi c'est important d'en trouver
plus de quatre c'est que du coup on va
pouvoir variabiliser ses horaires le
soir vous allez pouvoir rentrer avec la
personne qui repart à l'horaire qui vous
convient tous les soirs sur toute la
France on a à peu près 30000
utilisateurs alors le le chiffre est pas
hyper pertinent sur toute la la France
parce qu'évidemment ils sont répartis
sur tout le territoire et la majorité
d'entre eux trouvent pas de covoitureur
c'est pour ça que je vous parlais à
Saint-Quentin de 8 personnes sur 10 et
sur 5tin on a à peu près 1000 1000
personnes nous sommes sur une auprès
d'une grande entreprise oui d'un grand
groupe mêême euh pourquoi vous êtes là
aujourd'hui alors on est là pour
sensibiliser les salariés au covoiturage
parce qu'en fait je vous ai présenter
tout à l'heure la solution c'est
important d'avoir une bonne solution qui
répond vraiment au contraintes du
domicile travail en en fait sinon les
salariés s'inscrivent pas et vous créez
pas ce réseau justement pour passer à
l'acte vous proposez un petit challenge
ou de WAZ up tour est-ce que vous pouvez
m'en parler alors le WAZ up tour donc
c'est un challenge inter entreprise
organisé sur la communauté
d'agglomération de de Saint-Quentin donc
le principe en fait ça va être avec une
mascotte orange qui un petit klaxon donc
qu'on va distribuer à certains
covoitureurs qui pourraient aujourd'hui
covoiturer mais qui l'ont pas encore
fait le but ça va être tout simplement
dans la semaine quand on récupère la
mascotte covoiturer avec avec quelqu'un
sur l'application lui passer la mascotte
et lui il va ensuite la repasser à un
autre c-oitureur pour faire une espèce
de chaîne de coiturage et leur donner
une bonne raison de en ce début d'année
2015 coiturer une première fois vous
parlez de ce grand groupe justement qui
nous accueille aujourd'hui on va écouter
quelques instants Jacques Baum le
responsable des relations extérieures et
de l'animation du campus pour nous dire
pourquoi ils acceptent de travailler
avec WAZ up nous voyons dans
l'application W up plusieurs points
positifs d'une part la simplicité le
fait que ça permet de correspondre à nos
horaires qui sont des horaires on va
dire ouverts sans contraintte puisque
nous sommes une entreprise de services
bancairire où les collaborateurs ont des
plagesoraires très différentes les unes
des autres donc ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point on considère que
dans la solution W up il y a aussi
d'autres avantages sur le fait que notre
entreprise est engagée sur le
développement durable et que les
tableaux de bord que nous fournit W up
correspond à ça ce concours il va se
dérouler que sur Saint-Quentin ou sur
toute l'île- de- France alors ce
concours se déroule sur Saint-Quentin
parce que c'est là qu'on a créé le
réseau de covoiturage en fait vous
pouvez pas créer le réseau sans les
employeurs donc on travaille avec les
entreprises qui sont déjà nos nos
partenaires et a 5ant où on a en fait un
assez vaste réseau qui permet en fait de
faire ce relais avec avec cette mascotte
donc ça va se dérouler de fin janvier le
19 janvier à priori jusqu'à fin mars
donc tous les participants en fait vont
être récompensés parce qu'on va faire un
tirage au sort on parle beaucoup des
entreprise là depuis le début mais si
jamais par le bouche à oreille quelqu'un
d'une petite boîte ou le patron de sa
propre entreprise veut y participer
c'est possible ou pas alors c'est
possible puisquen fait il y a un W up
grand public sur lequel tout le monde
peut s'inscrire donc c'est aussi ouvert
aux habitants de de Saint-Quentin et
effectivement au au PME qui qui
entourent le créd agricole Renault
snakem ILT il peuvent tout simplement
communiquer sur le WAZ up tour à leur
salariés indiquer l'adresse web de WAZ
up et tout le monde peut s'inscrire sur
Android sur Internet rentrer son trajet
covoiturer tout ça est gratuit donc vous
rentrez votre trajet vous trouvez vos
covoitureurs et ensuite vous avez plus
qu'à coitureer avec eux on va vous
prévenir si quel l'un de vos coitureurs
a la mascotte pour que vous puissiez le
contacter en priorité et si vous voulez
participer au jeu mais que vos C
voitures n'ont pas de mascotte on va
vous apporter une mascotte et vous allez
à votre tour pouvoir la distribuer et
ben merci Julien honard pour cet
entretien merci à
vous si je vous dit commerce bio vous
pensez aux fruits ou aux légumes mais la
cosmétique est-elle aussi concernée
depuis 17 ans Samuel Cohen coiffeur sur
versaill utilise des produits
biologiques pour répondre aux demandes
de ses clients un sujet réalisé avec
Elodie
moine tacher pour moi il faut attend il
faut attendre une quinzaine de jours
pour que ça puisse repousser encore un
peu plus d'accord qu'te repousse encore
plus fort pour que je puisse reprendre
vraiment les racines des conseils chez
un coiffeur jusque- là rien d'étonnant
mais à y regarder de plus près Samuel
Cohen ne travaille pas comme les autres
depuis 17 ans ce coiffeur versaillais
n'utilise que des produits bio je vais
faire un blond un bain un bain avec de
l'eau
dynamisée là c'est du thé vert il y a du
thé vert un peu de des plantes qui qui
donnent pas qui n'éclaircissent pas mais
qui donne du brillant aux cheveux et qui
donne un blond je mets aut qu'il faut
pour
faire réparation sachant que l'eau était
déjà domisée pendant 5
he donc ce procédé s'adresse aux
personnes allergiques aux personnes qui
veulent du bio du végétal plante argile
pigment naturel de quoi créer la couleur
parfaite pour satisfaire les clients un
vrai travail de fourmis et de recherche
Samuel Cohen a débuté de manière
autodidacte en 97 j'ai démarré par que
devenu allergique au bout de 30 ans de
travail donc je pourraais plus exercer
mon métier donc les médecins m'ont dit
fallait arrêter la coiffure et j'ai dit
stop moi je suis déjà un peu
naturellement penché vers le
bio et je me suis dit il y a a des il y
a des progrès à faire là-dessus donc je
vais me lancer dans le dans le végétal
Samuel Cohen aimerait que ces techniques
de travail soi mieux reconnu dans le
monde de la coiffure on dénombre une
dizaine de salons bio dans les ivelines
des labels permettent de les identifier
Samuel Cohen lui est labellisé depuis
2009 avant de nous quitter notez ces
quelques rendez-vous le mois de janvier
c'est la bonne période pour aller
observer les canards qui viennent des
contrées nordiques la réserve naturelle
de Saint-Quentin en Yveline vous propose
de les admirer le samedi 17 janvier quoi
de mieux qu'une randonnée pour découvrir
la biodiversité de nos environs c'est le
programme mis en place par les maisons
de quartier de La Verrière de date à
retenir les merc 21 janvier et 18
février du 26 au 30 janvier c'est la
semaine de l'énergie dans ce cadre
l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et du
climat vous propose une balade dans les
rues du quartier des garennes de Guill
encour une balade réalisée avec une
caméra technique pour voir les pertes de
chaleur voilà équilibre c'est terminé je
vous donne rendez-vous le mois prochain
et surtout n'oubliez pas faites un geste
pour
[Musique]
l'environnement